hi it's me hannah and today jackson
wyatt and i are playing our very own
version
of crime scene kitchen the all new
competition series where america's best
bakers
think like a detective but bake like a
pastry chef
don't miss the series premiere wednesday
after the season finale of the mass
singer
only on fox so here are the rules
jackson and wyatt will secretly agree to
a bake that they want me to make
their job is to work together to start
the recipe
this is looking good and then leave 10
minutes in so that i can take over
my job is to figure out what they want
based on the ingredients they choose
and the clues they leave behind
what on earth i can't even tell what any
of this
is sugar flour
cookies it smells like bread but
it looks like the beginnings of a cake
wait what the heck
this is brie cheese
what
cheesecake cheesecake believe it or not
my kids are pretty bougie and brie
cheese is their favorite cheese
so i wouldn't be surprised if they
picked this is the crust
brie cheese thinking that they're gonna
make a cheesecake and i would even go
further to guess that it's a
peanut butter cup cheesecake i hope i'm
not wrong
so the first thing i'm gonna do for this
is get my crust made
and the crust is just sandwich cookies
and melted butter
then i'm gonna bake it a little bit to
set it in and it's actually really
simple
so this is ground i'm going to add my
melted butter and just mix it right here
in the processor
so that i'm not dirtying another bowl
get this in i like to take
a measuring cup and i just smoosh the
crust down
into the pan with the measuring cup
while it's baking i'll start the filling
and just make a little wish in the
universe that
i chose the right dish and this effort
isn't going to waste
let's get this filling going
that was a lot more dramatic in my head
so i usually use eggs as a leavening
agent in bakes to make everything super
fluffy and super tasty this recipe is
making me feel
like if i was on crime scene kitchen i
would win
that's how confident i feel right now i
hope i'm not wrong
okay that looks gorgeous just take a
moment to appreciate her
she's thick she's creamy she's beautiful
she's living her best life and she's
ready to become a real cheesecake i'm
going to add some peanut butter directly
into the batter i'm also going to add
brown sugar and then we got a little
salt when you have sweet
always good to have just a little pinch
of salt it offsets everything
so beautifully we got heavy cream just
to get that
really nice texture and then i'm just
going to put a dash of vanilla extract
here
let's mix this up you don't want to over
mix the batter
time to fold in the peanut butter cups
take your rubber spatula
you swoop it across the bottom and you
fold the batter over the top
like i just i just want to taste it
the most satisfying part is smoothing
everything out
getting it out to all the edges this is
going in the oven
for quite some time and then it's going
to cool for quite some time but it will
all be worth it
so as you can see my cheesecake has
cooled to room temperature it's settled
a little bit
and it still needs to chill more in the
fridge so i'm going to pop it in the
fridge
wait to garnish it before i serve it to
the kids because i want it to be perfect
i really hope i solved this mystery and
i made the correct dish
for the boys based on their clues
because if i didn't
that'll be a travesty that'll be
embarrassing and i'll be very sad
all right are you ready to see what i
made yes
three two one
[Music]
this is just what we want is that what
you wanted
oh yeah oh i got a lot of crust in mine
i can't taste the brie cheese well can i
tell you a secret
it's not brie cheese in a cheesecake
it's cream cheese
in a cheesecake so how do you think this
was
how'd it turn out do you think i
followed your clues pretty well
yeah i'm super relieved because you guys
i wasn't sure
but it's so obvious this was a lot of
work you guys
cheesecake cheers no bree to be found
in this oh did you eat it already
so don't miss the premiere of crime
scene kitchen wednesday at 9 8 central
only on fox
i never chef wyatt